well the jury have heard about three
weeks of evidence in this case but it is
now Theirs to decide they were sent out
to deliberate on their verdict the
prosecution case in this trial is that
Thomas Cashman was that gunman who burst
into Olivia's home on that night last
August he'd been chasing an intended
target a man called Joseph knee in the
street outside he failed to kill him
when Joseph knee managed to get inside
and Escape that gunfire inside Olivia's
home that the gunman outside continued
to fire through the door into that home
hitting Olivia's mother Cheryl in the
hand and fatally wounding Olivia now the
prosecution relies on it has relied in
this trial and a key witness a woman
known to Thomas Cashman who said that
she was woken up that night by him
asking for a change of clothes he got
into a home uh and and saying she'd
overheard him say that he had done Joey
the prosecution say referring to uh to
Joseph knee she gave that evidence
Thomas Cashman also addressed the jury
gave evidence during this trial saying
he wasn't the gunman that night he was
going about his business as a drug
dealer that night he said counting
thousands of pounds in in profit and he
says that that key Witnesses is lying to
try and ruin him he told the jury I'm a
dad not a killer he denies all five
charges including that of the murder of
Olivia and it is now the jury for the
jury to decide those charges